GREAT TO BE BACK.
HAPPY TUESDAY!
WE ARE BACK AFTER A LONG
WEEKEND, JULY 4TH.
HOPEFULLY THE FIREWORKS DIDN'T
FREAK OUT YOUR PETS OR GIVE JOE
BIDEN FLASHBACKS TO THE WAR OF
1812.
IN EITHER CASE, THERE IS A LOT
OF CARPETS THAT NEED CLEANING
TODAY.
WEIRD.
IT IS WEIRD HOW EVEN THAT
HOLIDAY IS CONSIDERED DIVISIVE
THESE DAYS.
AND NOT EVEN BY BRITT'S WHOSE
LIMEY WE KICKED, RIGHT?
I WASN'T EVEN BORN.
I WASN'T BORN AND I TAKE CREDIT
FOR IT.
BUT IT'S AMERICANS WHO DON'T
LIKE IT.
IT'S LIKE ONLY ONE HALF OF THE
COUNTRY GETS TO ENJOY JULY
4TH WHILE THE OTHER HALF
TRASHES, WHICH IS FINE.
IF YOU WANT TO MAKE JULY FOR THE
RIGHT WING HOLIDAY, WE WILL TAKE
IT.
ADD JAMES BOND BIRTHDAY.
BY THE WAY, HAPPY 109.
HE WAS GREAT AND THE JOKER.
BUT IT'S NOT REALLY THE CASE
THAT PEOPLE HATE JULY 4TH.
IT'S JUST THE PEOPLE WITH THE
PEDESTALS WHO WANT YOU TO FEEL
ASHAMED OF THIS COUNTRY.
IF YOU ARE A FAN OF AMERICA FOR
JUST ONE DAY, SOMEHOW THAT'S A
DOG WHISTLE.
YOU ARE CELEBRATING THE BIRTHDAY
OF HITLER AND NOT THE COOL ONE,
STEVE.
I THOUGHT IT WAS FUNNY.
A GUY NAMED STEVE HITLER.
HE DIDN'T THANK OF CHANGING HIS
NAME.
THEY ARE ALREADY MAD THAT YOU
ARE HAVING FUN.
YOU THROW-IN FAMILY TIME, THE
OLD RED, WHITE AND BLUE.
IT'S MORE AMERICANO THEN THE
LEFTISTS CAN BEAR.
ALL THAT'S LEFT IS A T-SHIRT CAN
AND FILLED WITH APPLE PIE THAT
YOU CAN SHOOT INTO MY FACE.
HERE THEY COME.
BARBRA STREISAND, JESSICA
CHASTAIN, BETTE MIDLER, RON
PERLMAN, ROB REINER.
THEY ALL WEIGHED IN.
AND WITH MICHAEL MOORE, THAT IS
LITERAL.
HE SAID THAT UNTIL ROE VS. WADE
IS REINSTATED AND CONGRESS IS
51% FEMALE, AT ANY PARTY OR
DINNER HE IS INVITED TO HE WILL
ONLY TALK ABOUT ABORTION, WHICH
IS FUNNY.
HE IS INVITED TO PARTIES.
THAT'S LIKE ME SAYING UNTIL ROE
IS REINSTATED I WILL NOT BE
SLEEPING WITH CHIMPANZEES.
I KNOW, IT'S THE OPPOSITE.
UNTIL ROE IS REINSTATED I WILL
NOT NOT BE SLEEPING WITH
CHIMPANZEES.
A LITTLE BEASTIE ALLEY HUMOR
DOESN'T GO OVER WELL WITH THIS
CREW.
IT'S THE USUAL TRIPE.
THE PAINTINGS ARE MEANINGLESS
THEN THE INSTRUCTIONS ON A POP
TART BOX.
ROB REINER GETS HIS CARDIO FROM
HYPERVENTILATING ON TWITTER.
HE CALLED JULY FOR THE STRANGE
THING TO BE CELEBRATING ALTHOUGH
NOT AS STRANGE AS HIM
CELEBRATING A SUCCESSFUL MOVIE.
SOMETHING HE HASN'T DONE IN
DECADES.
MEANWHILE THE DYING EMBER OF
WAUKOMIS ESPN FEATURED AN
ARTICLE CALLED BASEBALL,
BARBECUE AND LOSING FREEDOM THIS
FOURTH OF JULY.
THAT WILL RING A BELL WITH JOE
SPIX BACK AT HOME WATCHING THE
GAME.
ESPN IS LIKE WATCHING MSNBC WITH
A FEW BASEBALL SCORES THROWN IN.
IT'S THE ONLY NETWORK THAT
EXPECTS YOU TO NEIL FOR THE
ANTHEM BEFORE EVERY GAME.
THEN THERE IS NPR WHICH SKIPPED
THE DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE
OF CRITICIZING IT.
THE NPR ABANDONING THE READING
OF THE DECLARATION IS LIKE
CAITLYN JENNER ABANDONING MEN'S
SUITS.
OF COURSE THEY DID.
FINALLY ARE INSPIRATIONAL
PRESIDENT WEIGHED IN.
I WONDER IF LIBERTY IS UNDER
ASSAULT BOTH HERE AND ABROAD.
>> LIBERTY IS UNDER ASSAULT,
BOTH HERE AND ABROAD.
THE RECENT DAYS THERE'S BEEN
REASON TO THINK THIS COUNTRY IS
MOVING BACKWARDS.
FREEDOM IS BEING REDUCED.
THAT WRITES WE ASSUMED WERE
PROTECTED ARE NO LONGER.
>> YOU KNOW, THAT IS A PROBLEM.
I WONDER WHO COULD BE THE
PRESIDENT.
I DON'T HAVE TO.
IT'S YOU, YOU OLD COOT TO.
IT IS PRETTY FUNNY.
TALK ABOUT JULY 4TH.
JUST ONE DAY.
IT'S NOT LIKE A WHOLE MONTH
CALLED PRIDE.
I GET IT.
30 DAYS FOR RUPAUL AND ONE DAY
FOR BEN FRANKLIN.
RUPAUL DOES HAVE BETTER LEGS,
THOUGH.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE PROBLEM.
ACCORDING TO A GALLUP POLL THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXTREMELY PROUD OF THE COUNTRY
IS DWINDLING.
LIKE JOE BIDEN'S NEUROLOGIST, WE
ARE SEEING A DECLINE.
WHY SHOULDN'T THERE BE WHEN YOU
HAVE MEDIA REPEATING THE IDEA
THAT YOU ARE EVIL?
IT'S LIKE THE ABUSIVE PARENT
TELLING HIS OR HER KID THAT HE
OR SHE IS WORTHLESS.
GUESS WHAT?
IT MIGHT RUB OFF.
NOW IT'S NOT JUST RELIGION BEING
SIDELINED.
BUT PATRIOTISM TOO.
THEY ARE NOT COMING FROM SOME
OTHER COUNTRY.
THEY ARE BORN HERE.
THEY ARE NOT IMMIGRANTS.
THEY ARE HOMEGROWN.
WHY IS THAT?
THE PEOPLE COMING HERE GET IT.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY ARE LEAVING.
BUT THE BRATS LIVING HERE HAVE
NO CONTEXT.
THERE IS NO COMPARISON.
NOW WE MOCK THE INFLUENCES THAT
WOULD HELP THEM SEARCH OUR LIVES
MEANING.
THEY TURN INTO EMPTY VESSELS.
WE REMOVE GOD, FAMILY,
PATRIOTISM AND TRADITION THE
WORDS THAT MAKE UP THE TRAMP
STAMP.
WHAT DO YOU REPLACE THAT WITH?
SUBSERVIENCE WITHOUT REDEMPTION.
I DON'T OWN A BIBLE OR A FLAG
WORK LEGALLY I'M NOT ALLOWED TO
OWN SCISSORS.
BUT I UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE
OF BOTH.
YOU SEE IT WHEN BOTH GO MISSING.
WHEN THEY ARE GONE, THE
ALTERNATIVE IS PRETTY SCARY.
THE GOAL OF THE WOKE LEFT IS TO
REPLACE RELIGION WITH AN
IDEOLOGY THAT DEMANDS THE SAME
OBEDIENCE BUT WITHOUT
FORGIVENESS OF RELIGION.
IT'S INSANE.
AT LEAST WITH RELIGION YOU GET
TO HEAVEN.
WITH WOKE IZM YOU GET ON EARTH.
NOW IT'S BEING DONE TO
PATRIOTISM.
THE LOVE FOR YOUR COUNTRY IS A
SHARED EXPERIENCE AMONG PEOPLE
OF DIFFERENT PIGMENTS WHICH RUNS
COUNTER TO IDENTITY POLITICS.
IDENTITY POLITICS BELIEVES IN
EMPATHY AMONG PEOPLE WHO SHARE
THESE TRAITS.
YOU AND I CANNOT SEE EYE TO EYE
IF MY EYES ARE BLUE AND YOU ARE
NOT.
ACCORDING TO THE LAWS OF
INTERSECTIONAL WOKE IZM THE ONLY
HUMAN WHO GETS YOU HAS TO BE
EXACTLY LIKE YOU.
>> IT IS SO IMPORTANT.
YOU HAVE TO SHARE THIS TRAUMA
WAS SOMEONE WHO TRULY
UNDERSTANDS.
THAT'S WHY I CAN ONLY SHARE
THESE FEELINGS WITH ANOTHER
ANARCHIST POLYAMOROUS.
THANK YOU, DOCTOR.
I COULDN'T AGREE MORE, DEBORAH.
MY LAST THERAPIST DROVE A CAR
THAT USES GASOLINE AND SHE WAS
HAPPILY MARRIED WITH TWO KIDS.
HOW COULD SOMEONE LIKE THAT EVER
HELP ME?
SHE WOULD NEVER GET IT, BUT I
DO.
THAT WILL BE $500.
I AM SHORT.
CAN I PAY YOU IN A COUPLE WEEKS?
>> THE MAGIC OF TELEVISION.
IT'S NO WONDER PATRIOTISM WHICH
UNITES US OVER VALUES AND NOT
RACE IS A THREAT TO THE LEFT.
HENCE THIS TWO-STEP PROCESS.
REPLACE WHAT UNIFIES US WITH
WHAT DIVIDES US AND ERASE
REDEMPTION WITH HISTORICAL GUILT
MADE AS A PERMANENT STAIN.
COULD THE DEATH OF PATRIOTISM
FOLLOWED THE DEATH OF RELIGION
MUCH LIKE THE DEATH OF A HEAVY
DRINKER FOLLOWS THE DEATH OF A
LIBERAL?
MAYBE.
JULY 4TH IS NOW LIKE A RELIGIOUS
HOLIDAY.
PURELY OPTIONAL.
IT'S NOT A PATRIOTIC BIRTHDAY.
IT'S A REMINDER OF THE ORIGINAL
SIN OF REPRESSION.
THE SINS OF THE FATHER ARE NOW
YOUR OWN.
THERE'S NOTHING YOU CAN DO.
NO CONFESSION, NO FORGIVENESS.
THERE'S APOLOGY AFTER APOLOGY TO
THE MOB THAT SEE THEM AS
APPETIZERS.
AND YOU ARE THE MEAL.
WELCOME TO NIGHTS GUEST.
SHE PASSED THE BAR AND THEN WENT
BACK TO ORDER MARGARITAS.
OUR COHOST EMILY.
THIS COMEDIAN WILL MAKE YOU LOL
OH.
YOU MAY REMEMBER HER FROM SUCH
TV SHOWS AS COPS AND LIVE TV.
BOSTON CONTRIBUTOR CAT DEMS.
AND A FOLDING CHAIR WITH HIS
MONEY CLIP.
THE WORLD TELEVISION CHAMPION.
EMILY, WITH OUR COUNTRIES
BIRTHDAY YESTERDAY I TRUST YOU
BEHAVE YOURSELF BUT HAD A
PATRIOTIC GOOD TIME.
>> I DID.
I CELEBRATED.
>> THAT'S WHAT ONE DOES ON A
BIRTHDAY.
YOU DON'T GO TO THE BIRTHDAY BOY
OR GIRL AND DRESS THEM DOWN FOR
THEIR HISTORY, DO YOU?
>> BIRTHDAYS ARE FOR POPPING OUT
OF CAKES.
>> I'D LIKE TO SEE BENJAMIN
FRANKLIN POPOUT.
>> I WORK HERE.
>> I WILL WEIGH IN ON HOLLYWOOD
CELEBRITIES WITH ALL OF THOSE
TWEETS.
KATY PERRY SENT OUT ONE WHERE
SHE SAID WOMEN HAVE LESS RIGHTS
IN THIS COUNTRY BANNED FIREWORK
CITING HER TOP 10 OR NUMBER ONE
SONG.
THE INSULARITY OF THESE
CELEBRITIES IS SO TO ME.
IT IS SO NAUSEATING.
THESE COMMENTS ARE TOTALLY
DELUSIONAL.
SHE IS TALKING ABOUT VOTING
RIGHTS.
WE HAVE LESS VOTING RIGHTS?
WHAT ABOUT AND IN KENYA WERE
PREGNANT WOMEN CANNOT LEAVE THE
HOUSE SO THEY HAVE NO RIGHTS.
OR WHERE WOMEN HAVE TO VOTE AS
THEIR HUSBANDS DO OR RISK DEATH.
AND THEN WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
SCHOOLGIRLS, WHICH ARE THE
MAJORITY OF HER AUDIENCE.
THE REASON SHE IS WEALTHY.
IN AFGHANISTAN UNDER THE TALIBAN
THEY CANNOT GO TO SCHOOL PAST
SIX GRADE.
FOR HER TO NOT REALIZE THIS IS
THE GREATEST COUNTRY AND IT'S
AMAZING TO LIVE IN, TO ME, IS
ONE MORE INDICATOR HOW INSULATED
HOLLYWOOD IS AND HOW OUT OF
TOUCH THEIR OPINIONS ARE.
SHE NEEDS TO LEARN.
SHE SHOULD ASK HER HUSBAND WHO
IS FROM THE UK WHERE ABORTION
RIGHTS ARE MORE RESTRICTED THAN
HERE.
>> WHO IS SHE MARRIED TO?
ORLANDO BLOOM.
>> EXACTLY.
>> I'M GLAD WE GOT THERE.
HOW DID YOU SPEND YOUR FOURTH?
WE'RE YOU ANGRY, DEFIANT?
DID YOU SLEEP THROUGH IT?
>> I DIDN'T HEAR ANYTHING ABOUT
BETTE MIDLER AND ALL THESE
CELEBRITIES SAYING WE SHOULDN'T
CELEBRATE.
I WAS TOO BUSY ACTUALLY
CELEBRATING THE HOLIDAY.
THAT'S WHAT YOU DO.
IT'S NICE AND I LOVE THE
HOLIDAY.
I THINK IT'S GREAT.
IT'S CONFUSING.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LISTEN TO
BETTE MIDLER.
SHE IS NOT IN CHARGE OF YOUR
FREEDOM.
>> THAT IS TRUE.
SHE DEFINITELY DIDN'T SPEAK TO
MY HEART.
THAT'S FOR SURE.
I DID BRING UP THIS REPLACING
CERTAIN THINGS THAT WE REALLY
DIDN'T APPRECIATE.
I DIDN'T REALLY THINK ABOUT WHAT
PATRIOTISM IS OR EVEN WHAT
RELIGION IS UNTIL YOU SUDDENLY
SEE WHAT THE LEFT WANTS TO
REPLACE IT WITH.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
HYPOTHESIS?
>> I DON'T THINK MOST PEOPLE
THINK ABOUT THAT EVEN NOW.
ALL OF THESE TWEETS ARE LIKE NOW
I AM NOT CELEBRATING THE COUNTRY
ON THE 4TH OF JULY.
HOW MUCH WERE YOU THINKING ABOUT
THE COUNTRY BEFORE?
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE ALL EXCITED
ABOUT THE REASON FOR THE PARTY
TO WANT TO GO TO A PARTY IF IT'S
GOING TO BE FUN.
I ALSO DIDN'T SEE ANY OF THIS
STUFF.
I WAS CELEBRATING.
THEY ALSO THINK THEY ARE SO
NOBLE AND COOL FOR ALL OF THIS
STUFF, TWEETING ALL THIS STUFF.
I WILL ALSO SAY I AM NOT THAT
IMPRESSED BY IT.
IT DIDN'T KISS ME OFF.
IF YOU WANT TO BE MISERABLE, GO
AHEAD.
>> ALSO KATY PERRY THINKS BABIES
ARE FIREWORKS.
>> IF I HAVE TO HEAR THAT SONG
ONE MORE TIME, I WILL BLOW MY
HEAD OFF.
>> BABIES ARE HUMAN THINGS, NOT
FIREWORKS.
>> IT WOULD BE FUN IF THEY WERE
PART FIREWORKS.
YOU COULD LIGHT THEM.
>> YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO HAVE
CHILDREN.
>> WHAT IF WE FUSED A FIREWORK
ON TWO BABIES?
>> EVERYTHING YOU ARE SAYING IS
A BAD IDEA.
>> HEAR ME OUT.
ROMAN CANDLES.
>> YOU CANNOT EVEN BE AN UNCLE.
>> HOW DID YOU SPEND YOUR 4TH OF
JULY?
>> ME AND THE BROTHERS GOT
TOGETHER.
WE THOUGHT ABOUT A REVOLUTION.
IT WAS ALL THE RED TAPE AND ALL
THE WORK.
WE SAID SCREW IT AND BARBECUED,
LIT UP SOME FIREWORKS AND
WATCHED BASEBALL.
HERE'S THE THING.
YOU WANT TO FIX IT WITH
CELEBRITIES.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS BOOK THEM.
GIVE THEM A SHOW ON THE 4TH OF
JULY AND THEY WILL LOVE IT
AGAIN.
THAT'S ALL IT IS.
EVERY ONE OF THEM, THEY WEREN'T
BOOKED.
THE HELL WITH THE 4TH OF JULY.
I'M PRETTY SURE I HAD TO SIT
THROUGH NINE HOURS OF KATY
PERRY'S FIREWORKS ON THE 4TH OF
JULY EVERYWHERE.
HERE'S THE DEAL.
THIS IS WHAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO CELEBRATE IT
AND NO ONE WILL COME AFTER YOU.
ESPN, THE BROTHER THAT WROTE
THIS, WAS TRASHING AMERICA AND
TALKING ABOUT HOW UNPATRIOTIC OF
USED TO BE.
HE FORGOT THE GAME HE WENT TO IN
NEW YORK, THE YANKEES AND RED
SOX.
THE REASON WHY IT IS A DAY GAME
IS SO WE CAN HAVE FIREWORKS AT
NIGHT.
HE FORGOT IT'S A FORGIVING
COUNTRY.
YOU CAN BE ACCUSED OF CHOKING
YOUR WIFE IN PUBLIC AND PLEAD
DOWN, WHICH MEANS YOU DID IT,
AND STILL HAVE YOUR JOB AND
STILL BE ABLE TO GIVE AN OPINION
NOWHERE ELSE BUT IN AMERICA CAN
YOU DO THAT.
HE SEEMS TO FORGET THOSE THINGS.
GIVE THEM ALL JOBS ON THE 4TH OF
JULY.
NO ONE IS WATCHING BECAUSE WE
ARE PLAYING OUTSIDE.
PUT THEM ALL ON A SHOW TOGETHER.
>> HOW SMART IS KATY PERRY TO
NAME A SONG FIREWORKS KNOWING
THAT IT WILL BE PLAYED AT LEAST
ONE DAY A YEAR?
MY FORMER BAND, BEFORE SHE LOST
THE RIGHTS TO THE RECORD COMPANY
AT AMUSEMENT PARKS AND STUFF.
THAT'S WHY SHE IS MAD.
>> I WILL RELEASE A RECORD IN
WHICH ALL OF MY SONGS ARE BASED
ON HOLIDAYS.
EASTER BUNNY, THE EGGS.
>> IT WILL BE LIKE CHRISTMAS
AGAIN.
>> MY NEXT ALBUM WILL BE CALLED
PRIDE MONTH.
>> THAT IS GREAT.
IT SHOULD BE TWO MONTHS.
I WILL PUSH FOR TWO MONTHS NE